you might have big fakies and she sits
there and does the whole like oh spicy
spicy spice
ice cream's so good dude I can't stop
watching that I can't either where is it
on tick tock tick tock I tried to watch
Oppenheimer but I was too busy
[Music]
came across this [__] uh letter that
a an influencer wrote In order to try
and get a free car in exchange for
exposure what do they have
like other followers do they have 500
followers
send me the [__] every tomorrow a whole
card so here's the letter it says hi
there my name is blah blah blah I'm just
reaching out to hopefully get the
opportunity to test out one of your
vehicles I will return the favor by
advertising the vehicle on my Facebook
and Instagram platforms I currently have
over 33 000 on Instagram and around 6
000 on my business Facebook and over 1
000 friends on my original Facebook I'm
currently learning to drive
my neighbors who are both key workers
will be teaching me to learn in my own
car I currently own a provisional
license I am on disability benefits
because I do suffer with anxiety so I
find learning with instructors I don't
know quite overwhelming hence why my
neighbors are both willing to teach me I
would like to take this opportunity to
see if you would be willing to loan me a
vehicle or gift me a vehicle I would
prefer an automatic but I'd be massively
grateful for any if you are not willing
to gift or loan me a vehicle is there
any way I could rent one from you second
hand would even be massively appreciated
I am a 32 year old single mom who has a
big goal to pass my test by the time I
reach 33 I would love to be able to
drive my daughter to and from school and
I would love for you to help me achieve
this goal financially I cannot afford a
new car so I'm hoping you can help me
achieve my goal thank you so much you
know there's so many twists in this I
thought it was going to be way worse I
thought it was gonna be way worse this
is kind of respectful I was kind of
hoping it'd be like real yeah [__]
where were you hoping oh just like I
have like all these followers and like
it could really benefit your platform
and like I could be shining a light on
like your on your product all that kind
of I'm giving you a great deal yeah
you're getting so much exposure when you
work with me this is working how does
she have 30 000 followers and how is she
32. yeah that's a provisional license at
32. maybe she's hot wait provisional
license is that UK because we call it a
permit yeah yeah I think if it's
anything weird it's definitely she might
have big fakies and she sits there and
does the whole like ooh spicy spicy
spice
ice cream's so good dude I can't stop
watching that [__] I can't either where
is it on tick tock tick tock I tried I
tried to watch Oppenheimer but I was too
busy
it's 70 [__] milliliters that is the
wildest [__] I've never heard of anybody
advertising how many Facebook friends
they have as a leverage sounds like your
influence sounds like you don't have
brand deals dude yeah he's talking about
Facebook group or all friends business
but Paige has over 6 000 and then her
actual original Facebook has over a
thousand friends that's pretty legit
actually yeah she has a lot of friends
doesn't she so we're kind of like being
like yo you should give her a car yeah
the way that she wrote it what I mean
it's pretty common where if a new car is
coming out they'll do a campaign and
then they'll be like hey you can you can
we'll loan you this car for a couple
months dude I know some tubers who've
got a [__] Ford Fiesta not exactly a
brackable thing but they were stoked on
it well I remember that campaign yeah
dude oh my key is sold dude what's that
you ever do that campaign I also I
competed for that actually I remember
that was big for a sec I did a RAV4
brand deal and I just I couldn't even
drive it away I just had to take
pictures next to it yeah what didn't you
also get a Harley Davidson but you could
that one was cool I actually had the
bikes in my garage I could ride them
whenever but that's awesome the RAV4 one
was like they hit up all these
influencers oh we have this whole RAV4
campaign I'm gonna get cool and I
thought I was gonna be able to take one
home but no you just have to go and take
a picture with it I'm like oh all right
take a picture with a RAV4 hey don't
another [__] car don't leave them in
the [__] box because the Ford Fiesta
hate muscle head get off that [__]
they got to drive it around well it's a
fiesta but you still get to have a car
four primes are sick though hey Meathead
cover up your [__] test you scared
away the customers
what looks like you're about to steal
the [__] thing what was that what was
your heart campaign that one was cool I
dropped this bike did you well not
hardcore the Hardy one was cool I think
for them that [__] was a monster they're
trying to hit like uh the neck what
generation am I am I Millennial or
Millennials hit the millennial Market
that's such a boomer thing
it's dying it's dying hard it's super
dying hard yeah the youth don't [__]
[__] with Harley-Davidson yeah in
Glendale they have a whole like
Warehouse full of Harleys that's used
for movies so they're like oh we have
this whole lot that has every single
model
um why don't we rent them out to
influencers so they hit up me and Geo to
go and then every month we can check out
a new one and and we'll go there and
pick and then they'll deliver it to our
house on a flatbed which is [__]
still no they don't have that anymore
well we actually I think on our own like
conscience because we just had taika
like and we had to like take turns
watching them like there's no way that
we're gonna be riding so we're just like
you know what like we feel bad having
these bikes at our house and then after
like three or four months we just
canceled it with them that's nice of you
pass it on bro no I probably wrote it
more than Bart did and then you dropped
it
I was on I was in sandals too and I was
like God damn this is crazy and this was
right no you know what's funny
he doesn't wear shoes I didn't even
[__] like Drop it hard I was doing
like a little U-turn and it was like as
like [__] slow as [__] and it went
cook and I was like oh [__] they're
heavy they're really heavy yeah and then
like my dumbass was trying to like get
it back up it was like oh that's so it
was like 2 000 pounds and then this
neighbor felt bad and he opened the door
you need help bro and I'm like no I got
it and I finally got it up yeah yeah I
was just right I would just ride it just
to get mail just to have fun a little
bit and then go back that's how big his
house is his mailbox you're one of those
PO Box writers what kind of safe dude
this guy damn so yeah this chick
obviously deserves a car with some of
this sicker [__] brand deals you guys
ever actually got can I tell you about
one that I was about to get and I didn't
get it I'm like [__] you
yes you can it doesn't even make any
[__] sense so I literally got this
email
I think last month
and they said hey we're doing you guys
ever see those influencers do like a
whole military experience oh yeah they
do Army Navy whatever no well I was in
the Army for a day or whatever oh damn
so they hit me up to do a marine one
they go we love we saw like your family
Vlog channel that would be really cool
if you did a marine one would have sent
you send you the Quantico Virginia which
is a marine HQ you're gonna do all this
blah blah and I was like did they know
you're a marine they didn't know so I
was like dude that'd be [__] dope I'm
like I'm always talking about the
military anyways it's perfect I had a
really great experience in the Marine
Corps and I felt like it benefited me a
lot I would love to do it
um and we were and then they would send
me there and then they're gonna send me
to another like Afghanistan
that's a brand deal yeah yeah I know
yeah that's the new scam is let's get
these influencers to just do the war
Horus
we're sending you the front line of
Ukraine you're like oh that's kind of
cool I haven't been to you I was gonna
be uh it was gonna be three days in
um Virginia and then three days to
Mexico and check out the embassy over
there
and I was cool so we defended
and all this stuff and then they wanted
me to bring on a camera guy and you know
and it seemed like it was going to go
through and they're really excited until
they found out that I was a marine and
then they said oh actually uh we'd want
non-military personnel and I was like
what the [__] I'm like no one is gonna
tell you
like better than someone that has the
inside on it and then they're like no
sauce I can kind of understand the idea
of it being like an influencer who's not
an experienced Marine to go through a
new experience but if you're trying to
like right now recruitment is at an
all-time low right if you're trying to
recruit recruit old debtors yeah yeah
well if you get people that are actually
actually full dollar prior military that
is gonna work better than anyone else
like like Tim Kennedy is probably
packing more people into boot camp yeah
than [__]
[__] Brett man Rock talking about how
he liked the Army for a day you know
[__] that guy huh it is true though that
a lot of the people that set up and put
your deals are kind of dumbasses man
yeah they just don't get it brand deal
companies are hilarious though like they
rigidly stick to whatever the stupid
structure is and it's like you just made
that up anyway you could alter it as
much as you want but they don't they
don't want to deviate from the campaign
yeah no yeah they want to do as little
work as possible honestly so if you give
them a better idea even though they know
it they don't want to do more I don't
want to do more work no yeah well then
they have to convince their superiors
yeah it's just too much it's one more
conversation before they leave the
office they're just like I'm not doing
that [__] it's like it's not a big deal
that he has military experience they
just looked up a JK video where he talks
about lying about being Korean and
they're like it's just hilarious to me
that he's him being ex-military hurt him
with the Marines that's [__] up
I was like what the [__] dude and it's
all whoever was like the liaison was
just like I don't want to work this is
what I've been [__] perfect yeah do
you know any of the other influencers
who actually got the deal no they'll
send me links of Prior campaigns and
then they're like [__] a rapper
YouTuber that did it or a [__] makeup
YouTuber that did it you know you know
would be actually a good idea is if they
got Dylan and Mulvaney to do it oh my
God that'd be honestly that's the next
level I'd watch that I'd watch the [__]
out of it afford him why not no her
sorry her what's what's the best brand
deal that ever came to JK I would say
maybe when we worked with Scion and then
they let us do JK news at the LA car
show with Steve Aoki oh [__] that was a
really fun brand deal really because I
actually just enjoyed it so much that I
was like I would have done it for free
yeah well but unfortunately there's no
more Scion and yeah is that under Toyota
still oh no it was a Toyota company boxy
looking piece of [__] anyway it just
went back to being to what would be a
dream uh brand deal for JK a tattoo shop
that would sponsor all of the messages
that's pretty good how about a [__]
camera company that gives us video
cameras instead of Photography we had a
sick Road one back in the day yep we did
have a really good road uh brand deal
that one was pretty sick
road yeah that's how we got all like
when we were shooting like skits and
stuff back in there that's how we got
all these like boom mics wait these are
our video cameras that's like Ryan doing
how would a real estate brand deal we're
gonna stick office
that would be cool that would be insane
yeah a real estate brand yeah we knew
people that got real estate brand deals
you know what like in the whole Asian
American Community we're coming up
because we're the [__] bastard dirty
children that no one wanted to deal with
like there's like these Asian real
estate Moguls they'll be like oh you
need an office space use mine this place
has been vacated for like three years
and I'm like what the [__] what about me
and they're like oh we don't want to
deal with you guys
what about James Wang dude that's on my
[__] dream the [__] lawyer yeah
dude you sponsored us that's our brand
deal we just get put on a little
one-inch slot on his [__] place talk
about making it brother or like hey have
you recently been injured
called James Wang I've never had
brandias but we're too small for James
win you never have brand deals not like
that no not for Quest For Real no way
yeah not at that level that's crazy the
quest was do TV level you guys made it
like Beyond JK nah that's still I would
have assumed Paul Mitchell would have
sponsored you guys yeah dude they never
Paul Mitchell never no no we got a lot
of like stuff but nothing to the level
of like this is really cool that they're
giving us a car or something yeah
like because you got to promote because
like also you have to think about like
we you we didn't have like a regular
channel that we were uploading content
to oh and if you're gonna give us
something you got to give [__] 12
guys the same thing like what the heck
it would give us not scary farm passes
worth it but I've seen really cool ones
like like Redfoo got a [__]
um a Kia Soul because of the Kia Soul
hamster commercial oh yeah oh yeah they
gave him one of those did it get stolen
yeah this is stolen immediately it's
still around actually and then um smack
got a freaking super 73 from the
freaking oh I love those I [__] tried
to enter a contest for one of those guys
I actually thought it was cool it's like
trick uh bicycle that's like but it
looks like a small yeah it looks like a
small like dirt bike yeah they gave her
one of those and and like did the shoot
and everything and paid her wow wow
that's [__] sick she's way cooler
than she gets cool [__] though yeah
maybe I should go clean
[Music]